the mega
earthquake it's coming
we don't know exactly when or how big
it's going to be
but it's coming it will be
chaotic and with millions of lives on
the brink
california will be put to the ultimate
test
what kind of devastation could we be
dealing with
is california ready for something like
this
and what would be the economic impact
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a mega earthquake happens in
california
tomorrow eighteen hundred
people will die sixteen hundred fires
will ignite
seven hundred and fifty people will be
trapped inside buildings
two 270 000 people
will be unable to return home and
50 000 people will need emergency care
search and rescue efforts will last for
19
days these numbers are from the united
states geological survey
they've estimated that if a 7.8
earthquake hits along the southern san
andreas fault on a non-windy day
at about 9 00 am we will be thrust into
this frightening scenario
they are also warning that there's a 20
chance
the big one could hit the san andreas
fault
sometime in the next 30 years
some experts predict it could be a
catastrophic
8.2 magnitude quake
so what is the san andreas fault
well it's a boundary between the pacific
plate
and the north american plate the fault
extends into california
roughly 1200 kilometers from cape
mendocino to the mexican border
cities like san diego los angeles and
big sur
sit on the pacific plate the north
american plate
has san francisco sacramento and the
sierra nevada
san andreas is a transform fault
this is when two plates slide past one
another
the average speed of the moving plates
is
0.6 centimeters per year
although this doesn't seem like much
they will actually
lodge themselves together and not move
for years
and this is where the problem starts
imagine the damage as built up strain
finally releases
and breaks the rock along the fault this
causes the plates to shift a few feet
all at once
the sudden release of energy creates
seismic waves and
it's these waves that we feel as
earthquakes
the san andreas fault has experienced
massive earthquakes in the past
the great 1906 san francisco earthquake
is one of the most significant
earthquakes of all time
at 5 12 a.m on the morning of april 18th
a foreshock was felt throughout the bay
area
then 20 to 25 seconds later the
earthquake hit
the estimated magnitude was 7.9
and the violent shocks lasted for 45 to
60 seconds
it was so powerful that it was felt from
southern oregon
to the south of los angeles and inland
as far as central nevada it's been
estimated
that around 21 to 2 800 people died that
day
if the mega earthquake hits california
tomorrow
what sort of devastation could we be
dealing with
if it is the big one it would have a
magnitude
of about eight that would rupture a 322
kilometer stretch
along the southernmost part of the fault
buildings
built before 1980 are in danger of
collapsing
a recent study suggests that up to 25 of
the buildings
constructed to the current earthquake
code will be
unusable after the quake after the big
one
explosions could be triggered and fires
would erupt throughout the devastated
cities
landslides could lead to more fatalities
and damage
electricity and sewage could come to a
halt
along with transportation highways
railways airport runways and bridges
could become
unstable for weeks even months
one of our basic survival needs is
access to fresh water which would be
difficult after the quake the major
aqueduct infrastructure that
pumps water into southern california
crosses the san andreas fault so
it seems unlikely that this would be
unaffected
now if you're thinking it couldn't get
any worse than that
parts of the san andreas fault also
intersect with oil and gas pipelines
if these pipelines break the lethal
consequences
both for human health and the
environment will be devastating
but what is the economic impact well
california has the fifth largest economy
in the world so not only would the
effects be felt by
california and the united states they
would also
impact the world the estimated cost of
the big one is 200 billion dollars
33 billion of this comes from property
damage and
50 billion in lost economic activity
less than 20 percent of california
buildings are covered by earthquake
insurance so
most people will need to pay the
rebuilding costs
these same people might decide to
relocate to
other parts of the u.s this trend in the
dropping population
was observed in los angeles after the
two earthquakes of 1971
and 1994. the population decreased for
two years after both quakes and
these were relatively small having
magnitudes of
6.5 and 6.7
then there's the business impact not
just to california from the mass exodus
of population
but also california's importance to the
rest of the united states
over 40 percent of total imports to the
u.s
come in through los angeles and long
beach ports
and with the massive disruption of
transportation routes
especially those that cross the san
andreas fault
getting these goods to the rest of the
country will be
difficult to say the least so
with the largest u.s economy and the
fifth largest in the world crushed
would this send us into another global
economic crash
what would the future of the u.s and
global economy look like after
this well that's a story
for another what if